Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live. I am your host, David Flanagan.
Today, are taking a look at Waypoint from
HashiCorp,
a tool to build, deploy and release software.
Now, before we get into that, there's a
little bit of housekeeping.
First, please subscribe to this channel and tick
the little bell button to get alerts for
all new episodes of Rawkode Live.
We're gonna be exploring the vast cloud native
landscape together, learning along the way, and trying
to make all this mess a little bit
easier. So subscribe and join us.
We also have a Discord server available at
Rawkode.chat.
So if you wanna come and chat with
500 other cloud native and Kubernetes people,
then come and say hello. I
look forward to meeting you. And then also
we have a membership program on the Rawkode
Academy, which gets you access to exclusive courses.
Check that out. If you have any questions,
jump into the Discord.
Alright. Now to guide us on our
Waypoint journey today, I am joined by HashiCorp
developer advocate,
Taylor Dulzal.
Hey, man. How's it going?
Good. Happy to happy to be here this
morning,
evening, afternoon, just a a dollar sign time
zone, I think, is is pretty much the
time it is. Right? There's no there's no
time zones on the Internet. Right?
Exactly. It's just we're we're we're just here
as I think how it is.
Happy to be here today. So for
happy to e meet all of you. If
you have any questions during these sessions, please
feel free to throw comments in the chat.
Be more than happy to to expand upon
those answers, get things
just to kinda help illuminate on these concepts
and these topics.
Always always fun to have the opportunity to
do so.
My name is Taylor Dolozolt. Like David said,
I am a developer advocate at HashiCorp,
and I work mostly with infrastructure workflows,
application delivery, developer experience.
Basically, if there's something that we want to
do in the cloud and there's not an
easy or straightforward way to do it, let's
solve it. Let's do that together. Let's, if
if you want to see more examples on
that front, that's something I love taking the
time to do, meeting with people on calls,
and and just kind of really digging into
what the problem is. What's the problem that
we're trying to solve here is, is typically
how I like to try to frame things.
So,
have a lot of fun working at HashiCorp.
Really always excited to work in the cloud
and and see what everybody else is working
on.
Awesome.
Thank you for that. And I I think
we all heard it. You just offered to
fix everybody's cloud problems.
Darn it. I did, didn't I?
Like, oh, my calendar is all filled up.
Sorry about that. You're gonna have to open
up some more office hours I think now.
But
So thank you for that introduction. That's great.
It's nice to learn a little bit more
about you.
Now why don't you, for the people that
are not aware, share a little bit about
Waypoint?
What is it? Absolutely.
So great question. Great question. It's it's it's
almost like you've been practicing that
I'd say so what Waypoint is really when
when I talk with people about it, people
that have had the chance to take a
look at it might have kind of framed
it as a CICD
tool.
And you're right. Though it's so much more,
Waypoint
helps build,
deploy,
and release your applications,
your containerized applications.
And so when it comes to each of
those concerns, you know, you have tools like
Flex, you have tools like Argo, and those
are mostly focused on the release the, you
know, deploying release factors
of that workflow.
When it comes to build, I know that
I I haven't taken a look at Argo.
I need to.
I I've taken a look at Flux and
have seen that they're starting to add in
that build capability.
And to me, that just that checks all
the boxes when it comes to actually getting
an application,
you know, sharing an application with the world
or or showing people what you're working on.
So that's what Waypoint seeks to do is
just to make all of those steps easier.
If you're trying to deploy to Kubernetes or
Nomad or Lambda or ECS,
you have you know, the goal is to
have one platform to be able to do
that and to make it easy for operators
to actually set that up and give teams
the ability to choose what workflow works best
for them. Now personally, I really like working
in the CLI, but it doesn't hurt to
have a nice UI to be able to
go and look at things, make sure everything
is as you expect it to be all
in one place. You can do that again
with the CLI, but having that UI, that
single pane of glass,
the legendary mythical single pane of glass to
see everything that is important to you is
quite helpful. So that's that's what Waypoint is.
Really, the short answer is, you know, TLDR
is that it's it's a lot of things,
but mostly focusing on helping people solve problems,
helping people
deploy their applications and releasing them to the
world.
There there are two big workflows that it's,
that to to kind kind of help better
illuminate.
What Waypoint does is say you're a developer
and you haven't really
you know, you've heard about this Docker thing,
you've heard about containerization,
and you're just like, ugh, this is just
another thing to learn. That's it's it's not
something that's really gripping to you. You know,
some people love to write Docker files, myself
included, but say say that's not your that's
that's not your passion.
That's something that Waypoint really helps with in
the build step where if you have an
application that has a package manager, say it's
a Go app, a Ruby app, a JavaScript
application,
and you have a package manager,
what Waypoint uses is cloud native build packs
so you don't even have to have a
Dockerfile
and you can start building right away. Now
it's not going to be, you know, it's
not going to be a one kilobyte
image or or anything like that. It's not
going to be as reduced in size as
you might want, but it's going to be
a starting place, right, and and kind of
give you that that ability to deploy
your stuff and and get an example of
of what it looks like in in the
wild in the cloud.
If you do have a Dockerfile, you can
bring that with you. You can build for
that. And then when it comes to releasing
to each of these platforms, you you no
longer have to rely on that bash script
or that wild, you know, like, we do
deploys a little bit differently here as you
might hear at just about every company that
you work at.
So really just kind of hoping to unify
that workflow and make it easy for people
to switch out their platforms, to switch out
their build processes. I think that's really where
the power of Waypoint shows, frankly.
Alright. Awesome. Lots of great context there. I'm
gonna try and take everything you just said
there and surmise it as one line. But
then there's there's my mission. Right? So is
would it be would it be fair to
say that Waypoint as to software, what Terraform
is to infrastructure?
Exactly. Wonderful summation. Waypoint has this concept of
plug ins kind of and then you see
that with providers in Terraform. So whether you're
deploying to Kubernetes or to Lambda, you you
are working with these different contexts in these
different plug ins.
Okay. So one would use tariff oh, sorry.
One would use Terraform to spin up some
VMs or some bare metal
Kubernetes cluster,
then they who can Waypoint and it will
deploy their application to that platform.
What about the Exactly. Continuous integration stage? Is
that something that Waypoint handles as well? I
think you kind of maybe said yes there
with the Dockerfile a bit. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. That's what's really nice is that it's
at the current point in time, Waypoint doesn't
have that capability to to act as an
Argo as a flux
type of platform just yet. That's something that
we're talking about with the team. And so
I'm I'm really invested in kind of what
those workflows will look like. Right now, it's
I do have a demo today. It'll kinda,
like, showcase what it is to deploy a
Lambda application when you get that set up
with GitOps and if you were to make
a change and and kinda push that forward.
So that's that's that's quite cool. So I'll
I'll be showing that today and kinda, like,
what that workflow looks like.
But when it comes to the the the
piece that's missing there is is
authentication
and and tighter integration with Kubernetes.
So being able to
Waypoint has a server and then it has
a runner,
in its architecture. I'll also share out a
a link on that front too as to,
you know, how you can better understand Waypoint's
architecture.
But that's that's
that's really cool to see working and running
and and yeah. That could talk for a
very long time about it. So it's it's
quite nifty.
Alright. Well, you've teased the demo a few
times now. So why don't we get your
screen shared? Let's head over and I'll just
keep throwing questions at you as we move
through.
Fantastic.
Alright. So
you should see the
so you should see my browser window.
It's it's got my my homepage loaded on
it
for for for today for today.
So what I'm gonna be doing today is
quite a few things.
I
don't have two demos for you. I've got
three demos for you. So we'll do a
hat trick of demos. Fingers crossed. These are
all live. So fingers crossed everything goes swimmingly.
Let's so we'll we'll get right into it.
The the repository I'm gonna be working from
today is on on my username. I I
can share these out a little bit later.
My Waypoint GitOps repository.
In here, I've got some Terraform.
I do have to backport some things, so
I'm actually gonna go ahead and set up
an EKS cluster
using this repository. I've updated this EKS in
action repository
with examples for Terraform1.0
as well as added KMS keys and just
kind of made a little bit easier debugging
experience for, you know, for for people that
want to kind of have that experience as
well as add dependable so I can tell
when things are out of date, which, you
know, pretty pretty helpful, I'd say. Alright.
So
I'm gonna jump into this Waypoint
GitOps repository
here. But first, let me kick off this
I'll just run that off to the side.
So I'll go ahead and run a oh,
wanna know something? Probably would help to see
this. Right? Okay. Yeah. Was about to add.
Always always always a plus.
Okay.
Terraform, Annette.
Alright.
I'm gonna go ahead and kick this off.
Terraform.
I've already done plans and applies with this,
so I have a high confidence this is
going to work. So I'm gonna go ahead
and do what I call Terraform YOLO, which
is going to be this auto approve appended
here. People,
please don't do this in production. I'm a
trained professional, so mistakes are okay.
So I'll I'll I'll drag this shell off
to the side and kinda let that go,
and it is off to the races. Awesome.
K. I'll bump this up as well. So
let's get started. Let's get started. So I'm
going to be starting from scratch today.
We're going to be installing the Waypoint server
and showcasing,
the the entire workflow from zero to Waypoint,
with with production applications.
Granted, I I don't think that any of
these need a fully staffed team to administrate
or operate, but, you know, who knows? Who
knows?
Okay. So
let's go ahead and get started. So first,
what we're gonna want to do is we're
going to want to install Waypoint.
So Waypoint I'll actually go back to my
browser.
I'm
on a Mac machine,
and one of the easiest ways to get
started with Waypoint is to just use brew.
You can tap HashiCorp's tap where we maintain
and release all of our software, and then
you can just install it using these instructions
here. We do support ARM. We do support
a whole bunch of other builds.
Please feel free to refer to the downloads
page, and we've got some guidance for you
there. Also, learn.hashicorp.com
has some pretty good walk throughs of this
as well. Or if you're hitting a snag,
please at me. Let's let's work through that.
So
good news is I already did that kinda
like the pulling out the cake from underneath
the countertop. I've already done that. I've already
gotten Waypoint installed. So if we do Waypoint
version here, we'll see that Waypoint zero five
is here. We're getting an error when showing
the server as is expected. We don't have
that set up just yet.
I've I've neglected to say too that Waypoint
zero five just came out yesterday,
so you'll see a few of the new
features in here. All these demos kinda focus
on zero four functionality, but, don't fret. We've
got, we've got some zero five niceness in
here, some zero five sparkle, in here that
we'll be walking through. Cool.
So,
how do we install Waypoint? So we install
Waypoint by doing this. So we want to
just Waypoint install. We wanted to find the
platform that we're going to install Waypoint on.
Today, we're gonna install on two platforms. So
while I'm spinning up Kubernetes on the side,
right now, I'm just gonna run this in
Docker just to give you an idea of
how to install it locally.
There are some features that you won't get
when you install Waypoint locally on your machine,
and I'll get into that here in just
a little bit.
Alright. So let's go ahead and get this
installed.
And this won't take too long to to
get done, but really straightforward. It's nice to
be able to have have this kind of
experience and not have to, you know, mess
around with configuration, things like that. It's it's
it's nice and simple. So we can see
that Waypoint's been installed. It's been it's been
configured.
Let's load up that UI. So if I
if I type in our let's let's do
a version here, and then now we'll see
both the CLI and that server are the
versions that we want to see.
Let's say that we want to take a
look at the UI. So how do we
do that? The UI is
has a is backed by a token system.
Waypoint zero five released this capability to integrate
with OpenID
Connect. So if you want to use GitLab,
if you want to use Google, you have
the option to do that and then invite
users that way. We're not gonna get into
that today. We're just going to authenticate here
and use that token system.
So you'll see this is connecting over HTTPS,
so we are almost secure, as secure as
can be on local host. That's why we're
getting this alert. So we're just gonna go
ahead and proceed. This is as expected.
So great. We have installed the Waypoint server.
Now as of, I think it was Waypoint
zero three, we had this capability of runners,
within Waypoint. So, not only when you install
your server, you also get one runner.
So what that does is it handles things
like
handling runs and configurations and things in the
back end. That's going to be crucial for
our GitOps workflow that we're going to work
with today.
Alright. So we've installed Waypoint server,
and now we can actually take this for
a spin and actually get an application deployed.
So let me go ahead and set this
up side by side, and let me also
bump this up just a little bit too.
K. So
you'll see we have a few directories here.
So these these are our demos. These are
in fact our demos.
Let's let's kick things off with the GitOps
demo. So
the way that Waypoint works is that you
can run different commands in Waypoint, obviously. The
first one that we're gonna want to run
is init.
This is going to initialize our project, and
then you actually don't have to refresh this.
In real time, it will appear. It takes
just a second, and there it is. So
we have that loaded,
and and and we're good to go. We
could run Waypoint up, and then this would
go ahead and install just about everything that
we need
for this demo. So what is this, though?
Let's let's actually learn about what we're going
to deploy before we go ahead and do
that. So let's jump in here into GitOps.
My apologies. I'll bump this up.
Alright.
And then let's let's use some.
My goodness. I never remember my hot keys
when it matters.
There it is. Okay.
And then let's set the language.
Language mode. Let's just do a terraform because
HCL is HCL is fun. JSON would be
fine, but HCL is better better colors.
So what are we doing here? So we
define the project name GitOps because that's what
we're going to showcase is the GitOps workflow
in this demo.
So in this application stanza, we'll see that
we have a build step. Great.
We're going to be using Docker to build
out this image.
Inside of this build stanza, we have a
registry, and we're gonna be using AWS's
ECR, the elastic container registry,
because when we deploy to Lambda,
that is all that we are allowed to
use, from from Amazon's guidelines.
So, wouldn't recommend this in production, setting the
tag to latest, but Waypoint does have the
capability. There are stubs that you can put
in so you can get like a SHA
value. You can iterate
Waypoint
zero variables,
and so you can kind of define some
other things if you kind of want to
decorate this a little bit better or fill
this in with a little bit more certainty.
Again, definitely definitely don't recommend latest for for
anything unless you unless you like puzzles, escape
rooms, and the like, or 3AM calls. Those
are I'm I'm not a fan of of
many of those things, but, mostly mostly last
one. Escape rooms are fun.
Awesome.
Next is our deploy step. So,
deploy and release sounds similar, but they are
in fact different.
So what what what does that mean? Deploy
the Stanza,
we we specify which plug in we want
to use within Waypoint. So we're gonna be
using Lambda, and we're deploying to The US
West 2 region. I live in Los Angeles,
California, so this is closer to me. Little
bit better, latency time. We could get really
crazy and use local, local availability zones, but
haven't, haven't gotten there just yet.
Lastly, we specify that for the release. So
that's deploying. That's actually pushing our image onto
or or application onto the platform of our
choice, in this case, Lambda.
But how do we actually tell Amazon,
let's shift to that new version? You know,
say I have three versions. I wanna go
from two to three.
That final piece release is actually going to
to specify
that we need to shift traffic
over.
And so that is, that is everything today.
Let's go ahead and take a look at
our actual,
application that we're deploying today. This is a
very simple Ruby application.
Apologies for all the all the you need
to update your system. That's
try to do that just about every five
minutes, but clearly, failed.
So this is pretty simple application.
We can see that we this is just
handling a we're gonna be making a call.
This is gonna return very, very simple, straightforward
HTML,
and and we can see it's gonna say
happy day ending in y name.
So we could probably make that a little
bit more specific too, but we'll go ahead
and handle that after we get this deployed.
That's maybe that's a feature request we'll get
from our stakeholders. Let's let's find out.
So that's that's the application. We do have
a Dockerfile for this as well, so we're
not gonna be using those cloud native build
packs to craft this image.
So this is, again, pretty pretty straightforward.
Feel free to to ask any questions on
these fronts if you have time.
Instead of calling Waypoint up and actually running
this manually, what I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna use that GitOps workflow
right out of the gate. So we've initialized
our project, which is necessary. You can't
you could set this project up completely within
the UI,
but but with I I like having that
Waypoint configuration file because it's it's a it's
a declarative state.
When working with any kind of operations or
deployments,
declarative state to me is just something that's
really important to have because then we know
what we're looking to expect.
So awesome.
So let's jump in here into GitOps. Let's
actually manage this through the UI just to
kinda get an idea of all the fields
available. You can do this through the CLI,
but for for demo's sake, it's a little
bit easier to walk through when we've got
a UI.
So you can see here the input variables
is is one of the new features of
zero five. We won't walk through through that
today.
Alright.
So
we have our
repository here. I'm just gonna go ahead and
grab this HTTP
endpoint from GitHub,
and we can put that in here.
This GitRef, we could use head, but I'm
just gonna go ahead and use main. You
know, let's let's just push to let's just
push to main. I think that's how people
do deploys now. Right? Sounds sounds safe.
And then we're gonna wanna specify which actual
path that we're going to want to look
at.
This this demo is kind of a a
mono repo, so we have different folders for
different demos. So I'm gonna go ahead and
specify that we want to look inside of
the GitOps
GitOps folder. And then we're not gonna use
any authentication. I know that sounds risky, but
this is a public repository,
so we we should be safe on that
front. And then I'm gonna go ahead and
turn on automated sync so that as changes
happen, they actually get pushed to, our our
deployment platform. So
I know that was a lot. I know
that was a lot to listen to, a
lot to see.
Let's, let's let's see if everything is working
as we expect.
So
the nice thing about Waypoint is that we
can actually jump into this build and and
kinda get some
the telemetry on what's happening and some different
logs. So here in a little bit, this
build is already kicking off. I didn't instruct
this to happen Because we're using that GitOps
workflow,
this is something that kicks off initially. So
this will take a little bit. I'm more
than happy to answer your questions at this
time, but this this probably take, a minute
a minute or two to actually spin everything
up, build, push the repository, deploy the application,
and then we can actually go ahead and
test it and and push some changes to
it.
Yeah. Could
can we just clarify the difference between deploy
and release again? Like, I'm not sure I
got that. Absolutely.
Absolutely.
So if you have an image and you
want to get it onto your platform of
choice so so in in this example, we're
pushing to Amazon Lambda.
Oh. There was there was actually one thing
I I forgot to do. I'll I'll go
ahead and do that in the background. That
is
we we have that Waypoint runner that I
talked about,
but it needs authentication to to AWS to
actually carry forth these things. So I'm gonna
go ahead and set that configuration.
I'm gonna go do so in a, in
a
different terminal just, due to some sensitive credentials
there. So I'll go ahead and handle that,
and then we'll we'll get this spun up,
and then we'll actually kind of start to
to kick around and get things pushed. So,
what are the differences between deploy
and release?
We've our our platform of choice. So say
that we have an image, a container image,
we wanna push to Kubernetes.
The deploy step for that would essentially be
the kubectl apply. It's actually pushing that image
and that deployment to your platform of choice.
And then,
with releases,
that's deciding where you want to route your
endpoints to which version of your application. So,
the deployment is really just kind of a
push operation or or setting things up, making
sure everything is is staged
appropriately.
And then, you know, you could almost think
of it as GitHub branches. You know? You
pushed up your code and everything like that.
And then the release step is actually pointing,
which is my default one that I'm going
to use for these operations.
It is it's kinda what's going on there.
Does that make does that make more sense?
A little bit. I think so. Yeah. I'm
just trying to kinda work it in my
head of of what I was doing. Does
does that mean that Waypoint and nowhere in
the future will have the kind of built
in primitives to do canary style deployments? Or
does that come down to the platform of
choice that we're actually deploying to?
My
favorite answer, it depends.
So it's it is it is a little
bit of both, honestly.
So as long as your platform of choice,
it it it allows for that to happen,
then you're going to be able to do
so. I I think that that's the the
the niceness of Waypoint is that we can
kind of try to
think about different ways that we might be
able to enable that. So that that might
be something that, you know, either that we
handle more of on the Waypoint side, but
if there is a platform
if that platform supports that, then that's gonna
be pretty straightforward
and and pretty easy to do.
Yeah. So if I wanna update my DNS
on a deployment, would I ever do that
in the release step?
Exactly.
So inside of so inside of here, what
this is with Lambda,
I I'll I'll I think I'll be able
to show you with this example
after I get all the credentials set up.
Lambda is going to kind of keep track
of all the versions that I push, and
so with release, I could actually shift back.
So if, if I've deployed, you know, a
a new,
title for for the web page,
you know, it's just going to diff default
to the latest release. But if there's let's
say, like, oh, no. I can't know, I
made a huge bug. This is this is
not what I wanted at all. I'm gonna
be able to actually shift back using that
with with Waypoint, which is which is quite
nice.
Okay. Is there any difference between running Waypoint
up and what you've done through the UI?
Absolutely.
Or or in
this example with GitOps, it's kind of list
it's tracking the repository itself and then facilitating
all of those operations. So I actually didn't
need to run Waypoint up.
What what the runner is doing, what the
GitOps workflow is doing is essentially running up.
And and everything in the UI should map
to that same type of CLI workflow for
sure.
Okay. So,
like, I'm trying to build correlations in my
head now. I wanna understand where Waypoint is.
Is can I think of it as like
GitHub actions or Jenkins? Like, is is it
a traditional build system with some extra stuff
on top or is it something else that
has the build that kinda and I know
that's a weird question, but hopefully it makes
sense.
Yeah. Absolutely.
It's it so it it does encompass quite
a few things, honestly.
It it's it's it's
it is a little bit more general, and
I think that's that's one thing that I,
is a question I typically get asked is
that, you know, is is this just c
CICD? Is it just this thing?
Really, it's trying to tie all of the
things together when it comes to application,
deployments
and and releases and versioning and builds and
kinda, like, make it all a platform. Very
it's like almost like the, the Heroku effect,
if you will. You know, kind of you
you would start with your Ruby application.
You would push that up, and then
Heroku as a platform is able to kind
of add in all this functionality to build
your application, deploy it, handle the c CDN
steps, handle your Ruby and Rails migrations.
And, so that was very specific to Ruby
on Rails, though. And then Waypoint kind of
operates that's mentally where I put it. And
then Waypoint operates in this space where it's
handling all of those things
for you
with the ability to have all these plug
ins too. So
future platforms that haven't been yet released are
going you know, are are potential place that
Waypoint could operate and and people could develop
plug ins for as one example.
Okay. Thank you. We have one question in
the chat.
So Raja Salan is asking, does the build
run as a container on the host?
Yes.
So
so what that's doing
so the
right now, this so I've installed Waypoint
server and actually, let me show you.
So if I do a docker p s,
we're gonna see a few things running here.
Now I've got docker
docker desktop running, you might see a couple
other things and and some other things from
previous demos.
You'll see that I've got this Waypoint server
running,
which is actually handling all of the API
requests and, like, you know, scheduling out all
of the the work that I'm I'm throwing
at the API. And then this runner is
actually, you know, is doing all of the
work for me. So looking at these logs,
this is what's handling the builds and the
pushes. So,
that's that's where all this work is happening
from a compute standpoint, and then all of
this is is on my machine right now.
But later, when I install this to Kubernetes
and and that platform,
that's where all of those things are going
to be executed with the with some exceptions,
and I can talk about that once we
get to that too.
Okay. And there's a a follow-up there. So
holy cow. Is this, your personal CICD with
a DSL for multi cloud app deployment?
Exactly. Exactly. So if you if you do
want to kind of fix that, you know,
you you build it. You should only have
to do that once. You know? If there
are different platforms or architectures that you wanna
build for, of course, you you you have
to handle those. But, you know, it's it's
nice to have that ability to swap out,
say, I don't want to deploy to AWS.
I want to deploy to GCP,
and I want to use Google Cloud Run
instead of Lambda or something like that. It's
it makes for stubbing out that functionality
quite easier.
Alright. Thank you.
Absolutely.
So we can see v two. Everything is
better with v two. We that got kicked
off, and this did fail because I didn't
have the right credentials.
Something that's nice was added in Waypoint zero
five were these we we had statuses and
reports, but they were just kind of like
a, you know, didn't work, did work kind
of UI, UX representation.
And now we can actually start to hover
over these things and get a little bit
more context as to what didn't work. So,
yeah, if something doesn't work, Waypoint's
going to do everything it can to let
you know why that that
you know, what happened there as well. So
we can see this failed and and we
know why.
Of course, you realize the reason why as
soon as you push the button or initiated
the operation. I think that's how that magical
law works, but yeah.
Let me know if I got something wrong
there.
Awesome. So this is going to push up
to ECR
and then we're actually gonna start to see
some things happen.
Now once
these items have been pushed, what's nice about
Waypoint is that it has a service called
Horizon.
And what Horizon is is kind of like
if you've ever used something like ngrok and,
like, a reverse proxy to show your deployments
and your applications to people.
That's similar to how Waypoint operates. Now because
I'm on my local machine, I don't have
that functionality
with with
this kind of deployment. It's not going to
share publicly my my machine or those ports,
which is like like, thank goodness, you know,
that that would be quite a bit of
trouble, especially for people that don't know that
something like that could happen.
So when you deploy to a public
platform though, that's when and it's publicly routable,
then you get that feature add and that
capability.
So once this actually gets pushed up and
deployed onto Lambda, we're gonna see a release
URL
and we'll actually be able to, see our
deployment URLs too. Because this is Lambda, there's
no way to wrap to that without having
that ALB and, like, setting up many ALBs.
So there is just the one,
which is handled in this release step, but
we will see all those deployments, but they
won't have those, like, if we click this
link, it's not, it it's not gonna go
anywhere,
currently.
Alright. Got it.
Cool. So we have our deployment. We can
see our status is unknown because it just
takes some time to evaluate that status.
And then finally, once that's released,
we can actually click on that.
I I have noticed that there are some
cold starts with this too, so it might
take just a second to actually get traffic
loaded in there, but no no stranger to
that kind of of outcome or operation. Available.
There you go.
Like, yes. Okay. Here we go. Here we
drum roll, please. Yes. Okay. So, yeah, it's
gonna take a second to load up.
And then let me double check what that
URL parameter is here. I think it's name,
if I'm not mistaken. Yeah. Name.
Yeah.
Yeah. Cool. So Okay. So just to make
sure I understand everything that has actually happened
here, maybe we could look at the HCL
as we run through this.
Absolutely. But this
from this Waypoint HCL file, we've described our
application which has a build step which uses
a Docker file and pushes to to ECR
Container Registry.
Once the build stage is happy and passed,
it moves on to the next phase, which
is the deployment stage where it's actually going
to create a Lambda function that uses our
Dockerfile,
And then there's a final phase of release
where it's going to connect the application load
balancer to the Lambda function exposing it to
the Internet.
Exactly. Correct.
Phew. Okay.
Very cool.
And I guess I mean, I can add
as many use steps to each of those
phases as I need to describe my application.
Is that correct?
Exactly. Exactly.
What's nice is the the ability for all
of those plugins. So I'll go over here
to the the documentation,
and we can see that there are quite
Could you zoom in on that? Yes.
Absolutely.
That should be good. So here in Lambda,
we can see all of the items that
are supported, all of those different flags or
options that we have available to us. So
if we wanted to, say, change that tag
from latest to actually getting the git reference,
we we could go ahead and do that
here.
And then if you wanted to take a
look at, like,
the the l b, that's think that's this
is part of core right now, so so
we don't have that documented. But
but Lambda, Kubernetes, other things like that are
referenced,
and then all of there's different context too
if you wanted to say say you wanted
to not for Lambda, but for other examples,
you wanted to just use local support for
your image because, you know, if you're running
your Waypoint server on your machine,
it might not make sense to actually push
your image to, Docker Hub or any kind
of container registry. Right? You might just wanna
be you wanna test something or, oh, no.
I'm operating in stealth mode. I don't want
I don't want my people to know about
my secrets.
You you you do have that capability. Support
too, I've seen there?
Yes. Yes. Yeah. I'm a big fan of
build kit, so that's awesome.
It's it's it's quite nice. I I'm excited
to see some more work done around,
like, Docker less builds and and things like
that. There's some
well, the team, you know, we just put
out zero dot five, but already talking about
zero six and some features on that front.
If you do wanna take a look at
the milestone,
as as things get identified for work for
zero six and some other, you know, minor
releases, things like that.
Definitely worth worth checking out on on GitHub
to see what is what what the team
is starting to plan and think on on
that front. It's
the more that can be done there, the
more that we can kind help enable these
non root type type containers, I think is
always React to root all the things. What's
the what's the problem? What's the worst that
could happen? Right?
Is it easy? I mean, I don't want
to say easy as a terrible choice of
word, but I mean, can anyone write a
plug in like if they were to kinda
sit down and spend a bit of time?
It's not terribly complex, I hope.
Absolutely.
Absolutely. It's and more than welcome to. If
if that's something that you you're you're really
keen on doing,
please feel free to reach out on that
front too. I I haven't built one yet.
I I I'm looking to do so soon,
as well as, like, use feature flags and
there's like,
it's it's unfortunate. We only have, you know,
the time that we do today to to
to chat. You know? But, otherwise, I go
into so many features, but happy to happy
to do that offline, happy to do that
on Twitter or email or whatever to jump
on a Zoom call. But
there there is things like dynamic configs and
using configuration maps or secrets in Kubernetes.
And, you know, if that changes your reload
your application,
live reload it.
There integrate with Vault so that you don't
have to pull those credentials from
one source or another, you know, make it
a one time password. There's
there's even though this project is still relatively,
you know, new, it's there's so many things
that that are
in it's just chock full of features and
enables quite quite a many
So
we do see our application is running and
working.
In the interest of time, I'll I'll I'll
spare you, some some changes and things like
that, but, just because I forgot that first
step. But, but if I wanted to change
this to,
you know, change this to Friday, I I
could go ahead and do that, push that,
and then Waypoint's gonna go ahead and
if I choose the right browser tab.
Waypoint's gonna go ahead and load that in,
show that build, show that deployment, and then
go ahead and release it.
Really, really fantastic.
The more that gets added to this, I'm
I'm I'm really excited to see it start
to kind of evolve to match some features
within and Argo and make it easier for
for people to actually load these things up.
Is it possible to have gated releases,
like, that require manual approval
of some way?
I I've been asked that question a few
times. I'd there there is.
One way to do it is you could
use GitHub actions, for example, and then use
those gates on whether it be a quality
gate, whether it be a manual gate, and
then you could actually so so Waypoint has
the
help.
So Waypoint has all of these different actions
that you can run. Build, release, and deploy
can be run separately. So if you wanted
to say build it and then like hold
off, let's let me, you know, I wanna
make sure this this check sum is okay
or whatever it might be. You could actually
run those atomically
rather than just running up. Up is just
kind of like
the the
I can't remember what it was in Ruby,
but I'll remember it someday.
The the was it, like, d b seed
migrate,
all of those things? There was a command
that you could just, like, do everything, and
it it works, like, 5% of the time.
But if it did, that was really nice.
But, yeah, you you do have those options
available to you. And then that's the way
I've seen it done so far is whether
it be whatever
CI platform that you have, you could separate
that if you want it. Okay. Thanks.
Absolutely.
Awesome.
Well, that is our first demo. That is
GitOps and quite straightforward to use. I never
use the word easy because easy is is
is never easy. Let's just be fair.
Awesome.
I'm gonna go ahead and take a look.
Oh, I've got some good news. Our EKS
cluster has been set up successfully,
and looks like that is ready to go.
So let's let's get let's
get dangerous here.
So
we unfortunately,
listing my file system might contain some spoilers,
but Yep. Let's go ahead and move into
the kube control
demo,
and let's let's talk about what that is.
So
in zero four,
we got this capability for so
let me step back for a second. Waypoint
contains the ability to deploy to Kubernetes.
But let's say, you know, HCL is nice
and all. It's pretty straightforward,
but
let's let's
you know, what if we have some
deployment YAML that we have instead. Right?
I don't wanna have to rewrite all my
code. That doesn't make sense. Right? Let's
the goal is to meet people where they're
at when it comes to making these these
processes easier. Right? That's the hope hopefully, the
goal.
So in this example, I've got a pretty
pretty straightforward, pretty simple
deployment here, and then I'm gonna go ahead
and be building
this this Python application. So you can see
we've got a requirements text here.
Other fun thing about this is that or
or no. This one's not gonna use,
Cloud Native Buildpacks. I I I don't have
any demos for that today, but we get
to see
a Dockerfile with a little bit more to
it, and and then we can kinda walk
through that Waypoint
deploy really quick too.
Let me go ahead.
At some points in time, I I I
I've been talking with the teams about, like,
HCL colorization,
tokenization, and support. Right now, we do have
oops.
Here's my Terraform. We do have Terraform, obviously.
But when it comes to creating something for
HCL, I know there are couple of Versus
Code plug ins for that. But when it
comes to visualizing things, I think the intent
is to want to provide a nice Terraform
experience, a nice Waypoint experience, and kind of,
like, make that customization,
something that's a little bit better within Versus
Code. So if you have any ideas on
that front, please please feel free to forward
them, and I'll get them to the right
team members. But, that's something that's one of
my personal selfish wants is is this ability
to kind of have this nice, like, tokenization
of Waypoints and and things like that. Right
now, I'm just changing my language for Kubernetes,
but fingers crossed, we can we can make
this happen.
Awesome.
So
this so let's walk through this this this
demo. So Kubernetes apply.
Like I said, we have this Kubernetes support,
but what if we want to use YAML?
Waypoint zero four releases capability so that we
can actually perform these kube control apply types
of operations.
So in this in these examples, we won't
actually see that release because we won't have
an artifact to to to look at or
or to gain, but we will see that
final deployment.
So let's go ahead and and do that.
Here,
I've I've specified some labels that I want
to add to our deployment.
So that's just an arbitrary assignment. Right? You're
you're just making up that name labels. That's
nothing special in the ACL. Okay.
Exactly. Yeah. This this this is a callout
for the application stanza,
but but like the service environment, all of
these are are completely subjective. Yeah. We could
alright. Shh. Don't tell anyone. We're just gonna
we're just gonna push this live. Could you
change labels to just tailor? Could you call
it tailors?
This this one is within
the Waypoint's
name spacing. Alright. Okay. So this this will
actually track to to the labels object. But
but, yeah, these these here are are the
ones that are a little bit more subjective
or nonspecific.
In this build stanza, we're also gonna use
Docker,
and then we're going to be pushing this
to my repository.
This is going to use Docker Hub. And,
again,
don't use latest if you can help it
for for this demo. This should this should
be okay.
And then inside of this deploy stanza, you'll
see I've kind of flushed this out with
a little bit more information.
What this is doing is it's taking a
look at the path, and and Waypoint does
have its own functions just like Terraform, just
like other other instantiations
of HCL across our products.
So you so we're gonna be taking a
look at this path,
looking in the Kubernetes folder,
and then anything with the Kubernetes apply label
is what is going to be used. So
we could have a a whole bunch of
YAML,
but only specify, you know, the exact pieces
that we want to pick out.
Alright. I'll go ahead and save this.
Let's go ahead. So we've worked with Waypoint
locally. Let's let's to the cloud. Let's let's
go to the cloud.
I'm gonna go ahead and do
let's let me update my cube config.
We're using that EKS in action repository,
so I should be able to.
I also do use shorthand. So if you
do say see me just typing the letter
k, that it's completely intentional. I've aliased it
to kube control.
Kubernetes, if you haven't used it, has shorthand
as well. So I could write this, which
is so much typing. Right? It's like a
full sentence. So
I or I could just do this,
which, you know, looks looks kinda like standoffish.
No. You know, the word no. But it
gives us the same results. So
I'll show you I've got nothing up my
sleeves. I'll get the pods, and we'll see
that we've got nothing in our default namespace.
How the heck do we get Waypoint installed
on Kubernetes?
Well, it's pretty simple.
That's straightforward. Let's
let's go ahead and install that here.
We just specify that we that's that's that's
all. We just switch out the platform. It's
that easy.
Where's the complicated find the helm chart, rate
the values, fail, run the template, run the
apply?
You're just you're just doing it in a
same way. No
regular expressions. No go template string templates. I'm
really sorry if it's if if that's something
that you're passionate about. That's you you won't
find it here today.
Awesome. So Nice. I do I'm starting to
appreciate these these helpers a lot more that
we're seeing from commands. I know Stellium does
this. Waypoint's doing it. We're seeing it more
and more, and it's
yeah. I'm all helmed out, I've gotta say.
So
Exactly. It's it's it's well, you know, well
well stated, well charted.
I'd
it's it's I I I really like Helm.
I like it in terms of package manager
and being able to have all these options
and that declarativeness
when setting everything. I'm a huge fan of
the project though When it's using it is
fantastic, and I think that's the biggest thing
that I I hear feedback on too is
that, you know, when it comes to writing
a Helm chart,
writing Helm chart is it it can take
a lot depending on what you're going to
do as well as
the people that want to create operators and
then wrap their operators with the Helm chart,
and it's this, you know, gargantuan
her just
crazy feat to to put together. But alas.
Is there a managed Waypoint server by HashiCorp?
There isn't right now. So Waypoint's a a
% open source.
So so if there's something that you want
to see added, please open up an issue
for it.
It's it's it's different in that, you know,
as as projects get to different phases of
their life,
there's more help needed in certain areas. It
might sound obvious, but so, like, right now,
Terraform core we've hit Terraform1.o.
So if there's a core functionality or feature,
it's probably going to be the HashiCorp internal
team that's working on that as an example.
So it it are are we looking for
a lot of help there? Not not really.
But when it comes to providers,
documentation,
some other instantiations
of Terraform,
that's that's going to be a lot more
helpful and and and definitely a better use
of time.
I haven't tried opening anything up on Terraform
core just yet, but but, yeah, I would
it it'd just be harder to identify something
that's there because it's been so well built
out.
With Waypoint though, it's it's it's very open.
So if there is something that you see
or you wanna collaborate on, I I know
there's some,
like, good first issues that are marked in
there too. So
but, yeah, no no managed offering just yet,
but but who who knows what the future
brings?
I don't have any I I don't think
I've found a crystal ball that's been reliable
just yet, but, you know, goodness.
Awesome.
So looks like we do have our Waypoint
server installed on Kubernetes. Let's go ahead and
confirm that that's the case. Let's go ahead
and get those pods again, and we can
see we've got our server. We have our
runner.
Fantastic.
Let's
go ahead and authenticate and jump into that
UI.
Let me go ahead and close some things
out because that would just not be fun
to be in the wrong context.
Alright. So this should look pretty familiar. We've
got our projects. We don't have anything instantiated
just yet.
I'm not gonna be using the GitOps workflow
with these, so I don't have to go
and set any
AWS credentials or anything like that. I think
in the future, it's it's it'll be nice
to have
when you install this, kind of have it
bootstrap itself. And so, you know, that's I'm
curious to see how, we start to think
through that as the project matures and,
how do you how do we, you know,
bootstrap with Kubernetes authentication? How we bootstrap,
running in AWS with instance roles or or,
you know, switching policies and things like that,
assuming roles and whatnot. It should be an
interesting conversation.
Let's go ahead and initialize our demo here.
What this demo is going to do is
kinda show you again how we can get
that YAML into our Kubernetes cluster and then
kind of with the, you know, with our
Waypoint Waypoint
tinted glasses on.
So let's jump in here.
We'll see everything's all built out. I'll go
ahead and put this to the side, and
then I'll do a Waypoint up, and we
should be off to the races.
Okay. So while that builds, we got a
question from Rajasthanan
again.
Why do we always have to dash accept
toss?
So right now, the so because of that
integration
with the Horizon service
clear that up.
That is the terms that's the TOS right
there. So if you don't accept that, you
can you can work without that Horizon service,
but that is that's explicitly why that TOS
is there. And just just to make sure
because there is that transference of data and
you're linking together these applications in a public
space.
I just wanna make sure that people are
aware of that and, again, you know, aren't
aren't, sharing applications that they didn't intend to,
and that's kind of the the the TOS
thing that is at the end there. But,
not not, not you don't have to use
that if if that doesn't make sense for
for your team or for your workflows. Okay.
So if you didn't include the flag, would
it have prompted you to confirm or accept?
Okay.
I see you Exactly.
Thanks.
Absolutely.
So we
so here, I'd I won't be able to
click on this today either. For for the
next two demos, I won't be able to
click on that deployment and show off that
Horizon feature
just because I I I don't have a
service defined here. I could go ahead and
create one, but I I don't have one
defined here.
And then or or never mind. I'd I'd
forgot this one did work.
We get our adjective and that works for
me.
We get we get our adjective and our
our animal, and so we can actually see
this this service working as we intended.
Let me go ahead here and and actually
change out this code, and I can show
you the difference between releases and deployments too.
So let's go ahead into the application.
I think we're gonna want to go in
here to templates.
And then
very cool Waypoint.
Let's we can be more descriptive than this.
Right, David? Like, let's let's, make this
Presumably smashing?
Oh, I like that.
Awesome. Okay.
I like it. Let's let's let's ship this.
Okay. So I'm gonna go ahead and view
a Waypoint up. And you can start to
see now that, you know, we have things
like this. This kind of workflow makes it
really easy, especially if you're hacking on something
or or trying to get something out. It
really it works well for that kind of
workflow.
Know I've gotten quite a few demos pushed
out this way, and and it's just kinda
fun to have that feedback loop. That's the
goal of Waypoint is to make a, you
know, developer's
life a lot easier in that respect rather
than have to worry about getting all of
these things set up and and running and
working.
You know, you could actually focus on what
you're trying to do rather than how to
set it up to do the thing. Okay.
So let us jump in here, and now
we can see that we've got presumably smashing,
and then we could use this release to
to point back and forth. So I don't
know if I can jump in here.
Yeah. So I can jump back with Waypoint
release. I'd specify one and that would shift
it back. So Okay. I'm going here.
And then oh, and that's what it is.
We won't get that final
I I just had it mixed up. We
won't get that final release endpoint just because
we don't have that service defined, and that's
that's okay. We don't wanna share this with
the world. I I think there's there's more
that we could add to it. You know,
OpenID Connect,
some more features, different colors
would probably be helpful. So that's our second
demo showing off kubectl apply in that plugin
and how that works. Okay. Can can we
try something?
I just like Absolutely. You know, everything's worked
so far. So, you know, well done. But
let's break it. What's the feedback like if
my Docker build fails or my Kube control
apply fails? Could we maybe just intentionally
break the Docker file and the and the
the deployment template?
Absolutely.
Let's go ahead and do it.
So
here, we could try to
would you rather how how do you wanna
break it? Do you want to
we could either blow up the image. You
know, we could do, like, p ubuntu, like,
an the not so great smelling ubuntu.
Ubuntu. I like it. Or
just, you know, part of a pub sub
thing, maybe.
I don't know. We'll get somebody marketing to
work on that. Yeah. Alright. So if we
start to build up here,
we should see that so we get that
feedback immediately within our CLI. And then here
in just a second, we should see that
build fail.
And then we can actually go in and
introspect this, you know, what the heck is
going on. So we could see Docker login.
It's assuming that it must be private because,
you know, it can't find this anywhere in
the public registry,
which is which is good.
But, yeah, that's the that's the status report
kind of functionality that we get to.
Let me do that actually. So Waypoint status,
we can actually start to see that in
the CLI.
We we we get that visual representation of
it over here in the UI, but we
can actually see, you know, what's going on.
We don't have a deployment status. We don't
have that release status because we just failed
our build.
If we fix that and push that back,
then we're going to get, you know, available,
looks good, checked, you know, x x moments
ago. But but, yeah, that's that's what that
looks like when something fails. And then we
do have that helpful context
in terms of
go ahead and just run it again so
we can see that error.
We get that feedback immediately as well. So
if we now fix the image but break
the deployment YAML and then run a Waypoint
up, it's gonna do the build,
fill the apply. And then if we fix
the apply and run a Waypoint up, will
it skip the build and do the apply?
I
think
so it should do the apply. I'd I'm
curious to see. Let's go ahead and give
that give that a go. I think that
my prediction
is that
should
be deprecated. Right? A bit of you. Yeah.
Go for it.
So let's go ahead and do that. I
think it should break because I think Kubernetes
will hand it back. This Kubernetes one dot
two one that we're running to.
I I was I did run something earlier
locally where I had one nineteen installed and
because it is using my local cube control
applied binary,
that
that's where okay. Cool. So we we get
that feedback there.
It it was saying that
because of the the version differences, the cron
jobs and and it was basically having an
issue with an API version at at the
end of the day. And so I got
that feedback, but looks like we do get
that as well here
because that tag doesn't exist. And then we
can actually see
let's go to this deployment.
And then, yeah, we can actually see via
the statuses that,
that is not
what we wanted to see happen, which is
nice.
Cool.
Okay. Let's fix it and run it one
more time, and then I'll let you move
on to your last demo.
Yeah. Yeah.
Alright.
I'm just too curious. That's my problem.
Oh my gosh. It's it's the best thing.
Never stop being curious.
It's it's, it's fun working on these demos
too, frankly,
because there are so many, it's I feel
like that's the best way.
It's it is as as backwards as it
sounds, I feel like working on demos and
trying to find, you know, all these use
cases and workflows, to me, is a lot
of fun because then you get to find
these edge cases in these wild kinds of
states and
things that come up. I when you're working
with something in production or, like, working on
a pipeline, yeah, I feel like you don't
always get that experience because you're so focused
on making it work. You are with the
demo too, but, you know, it's with the
demo, you can be a little bit more
curious and push on it and see if
it's got any flex to it. So
always always fun. Awesome. So it still did
the build, but it was all cached. So
it kinda flew past it, but it worked
well.
Awesome.
And
there we go. Just like that.
Cool.
Any any questions on this front? Otherwise, I've
got a fun way to cap things off
with a final not not not quite typical
demo for y'all.
No. I think it's all starting to click,
and it's starting to make a lot more
sense in my head. I understand kinda what
its responsibilities are, what it's trying to do.
It's yeah. Definitely making progress on my end.
So all good.
Awesome. Awesome. Always a good thing to hear.
Yeah. If I can understand, everyone can understand
it. So
That's that's that's always the goal. That's always
the goal. Exactly.
Go ahead and actually jump into this. Are
you familiar with the Dagger project?
Yes.
So I I haven't gone to check that
out as much as I've wanted to. I
I really want to I I haven't done
a deep dive with it just yet. I
I I've been invited to the repository
and so I've gotten to like build it.
I've done a couple demos locally, but it
definitely something I've I've got my eye on,
you know. It feels like there's quite a
lot Dagger, so it's cutting edge. It
feels like there's a lot of crossover between
what what Waypoint and what Dagger are trying
to offer. They're both kinda using BuildKit or
can use BuildKit.
Except this is obviously using HCL and Dagger
uses Q, but yeah.
Really cool the way they they're both trying
to solve this this this problem. Like this
is a real problem that needs some better
tooling.
I agree. It's just too it's too specific.
There's no, like, ability for dependency injection or
or really anything like that for for this
kind of tooling. So it's well, you know,
like I said before, I I think that
honestly,
every single company I've worked at except for
HashiCorp,
they say it more tongue in cheek, but,
like, we do things a little bit differently
here. You know, it's it's it's honestly what
I've gotten every time I've been like, can
we go over the build system? Can we
talk through this? I don't really quite understand
how this works or how do you do
this here.
So those those conversations are as really I
find those really interesting
to to kinda talk through. Alright. My car
alarm's gone off. I'm just gonna quickly go
turn it off.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
Well, please please feel free if you have
any questions on these fronts to to put
them in the chat, and we can get
to that. Otherwise, I'll get things kicked off
while David handles one alarm and and one
rear in IRL status.
You know, like
like we've seen here. We've got some successful
statuses here, but, yeah, car alarms definitely definitely
worth getting fixed.
So
our last demo today is going to be
something a little bit different.
They're like, yay. Okay. Congrats.
Congrats,
David, on your on your car. Sorry about
that. I'll just leave you hanging there.
No worries. No worries. It's it's your show
now.
Yes.
It's actually, yeah. It was it was actually
me that did that with the car alarm.
So okay. Let's let's get into let's get
into the next demo.
And that is it's gonna be a Minecraft
server. We're gonna go ahead and run that
on Kubernetes.
We're going to deploy it with Waypoint.
And because
this image is already defined, we we don't
wanna build it. We kind of just want
to shim this together so that we can
actually use Waypoint to deploy this.
You know, probably not the most practical example,
but it is if you like playing Minecraft
and you wanna set the server with with
one of your favorite tools out there. Am
I right? Okay. So let's let's
let's take a look at how we get
this done.
Go ahead and do my favorite thing here.
And there we go.
So
you won't see things that look too different
here. You shouldn't see things look too different
here. We've got our labels, we've got our
projects, we've got our app stanzas.
The real thing that's different here
so right now, it's it's a requirement within
Waypoint.
You don't have to have a release stanza,
but you do have to have a build
and a deploy stanza as a bare minimum.
It's you know, we we've talked about this
with the I've talked about this with the
team in a few different contexts, but it's
my hope that these kind of get separated
out over time. But, you know, Waypoint doesn't
work best when you're not using it all
of the pieces of it. You know, it's
you you'll get those feature ads. You'll get
those benefits. But,
you know, it's it does work better together.
But if you did just wanna build something
and use Waypoint to do that,
that's that's something I'd like to see in
the future, you know, personally, selfishly.
Here, we're just gonna be pulling down this
docker image here.
What Waypoint does one thing I forgot to
mention was when we were let me actually
go back to this.
We're seeing all these builds, we're seeing all
these logs. Where the heck are they coming
from?
Waypoint injects an entry point
binary into your docker image when you use
Waypoint to build it. So in the example
of our lambda function, it was actually be
able to look at the CloudWatch logs and
pull those in. And that's the benefit of
the entry point is getting the application logs.
That's how we can then evaluate the status.
Is it up? Is it down? What's going
on? And then that entry point will allow
for some neat functionality in the future too.
I I can only,
you know, only only assume.
One one also thing to point out is
that in this release,
we
Mitchell and and the team wrote up the
architecture document with, oh my gosh, pictures. This
is so helpful to kind of understand, you
know, it's you can read things all day,
but like this, when you have this summation,
the the boxes and the arrows, really, really
makes for for some good good reading. Boxes
and arrows. Yeah.
It's it's it's it's nice. That's I think
that's what I'm best at drawing. If it's
like actual art, terrible. But when it comes
to boxes and arrows Yeah. Pretty good at
stick people.
It's a a mix for mix for good
past time. But, yeah, if you're interested in
the, like, internals and the architecture of Waypoint
and, like, really wanna understand the deep technical
pieces of it, definitely recommend checking out architecture.md
in the root of of the repository. Lots
of lots of time care and and and
just
chances
for illumination on that front.
Cool. So
apologies before I get too too sidetracked.
We're going to so I talked about this.
We talked a little bit about entry point.
Finally, this deploy step, we've
seen this before too. So this is just
using the Kubernetes apply. I've got a deployment
file and some other YAML items which you
can take a look at
right here. So I've got my deployment, a
whole bunch of things here.
I do update this I do increase this
initial delay seconds because since it is a
Minecraft
server, it has to generate some assets and
that does take some time. So
like David, I was I was curious and,
like, is different compute? Can I make this
any faster? But I had haven't really been
able to find out anythings while it's initializing
just yet. But if you if you have
some tips or some suggestions on that front,
please let me know. I'm I'm all ears
on that front.
We are defining a service here too
because I'm gonna want to connect to this
with my local desktop client and specify that
load balancer address so that I can connect
this. And if anyone out there has Minecraft
Java Minecraft on their machine too,
you know, you you would be able to
join as well.
Alright. So let's go ahead
and kick this off.
Let me close out things I don't need.
That's always a plus.
Okay.
So
probably probably getting the hang of this by
now. We wanna run our Waypoints in it,
and we will see that project instantiate.
And drum roll, please. Still waiting on the
team to add music sound effects to this,
but I don't know if they're gonna accept
that feature request. Yeah.
Like, oh, yes. Okay. I I would I
don't have a drum roll, but I'll work
on that for next time.
It's I I I got it. We we
have to keep doing streams because that's that's
yeah. That's that's that's where that's the magic
right there.
Awesome. So we've initialized this, and
we are connected to the right Kubernetes cluster.
Everything is good. We don't need any authentication
details because they're all accounted for.
The build is going to be very quick
because it's it's it's just a docker pull.
And I did run this as
did run a couple tests on this beforehand,
so we have that already instantiated
and good to go.
Cool.
We're not going to or we should get
this release status here in just a little
bit,
but looks like everything has loaded up just
like we wanted.
We're not gonna have the entry point because
we did a docker pull, so there was
no injection into
this pod. So we won't get those logs
in Waypoint. But at the end of the
day, this is really just, you know, off
the wall demo and that, like, let's just
get a Minecraft server up and running.
So let's go ahead and take a look
at the logs. I guess I could do
that with a sidecar injection as well though,
right, as part of the deploy step for
when you do use a Docker pull?
That's true. That's true. I I do like
that. And and and and, honestly, I could
probably take take a look at the how
that
how that Docker file is written, and then
we could actually just kind of, like, port
that over to be its own
Waypoint project or or file, you know, basically
put it into the repository. I like this.
I like this.
Yeah. TBD. I'm gonna have to open up
an issue for that. That's that can make
for a fun time.
So this is the main craft doing the
generation thing. Right? Okay.
This yeah. This was this was a fun
demo to work on because the fact that
there was so much going on with it's
it took like oh my goodness. It was
it was a very frustrating,
like, thirty minutes the first couple of times
that I was trying to get this set
up because it would keep crashing
just before it would like get here. So
so we we we yeah. So just like
this. This actually
I think it's
yeah. I think it might have crashed here,
but let's let's just go ahead and see.
Might have restarted.
Yeah.
It's it's always fun. Okay. So so, yeah,
it'll it'll do this. It's it's probably about
it's like it's finger fingers crossed. I think
it's like 5% of the time it it
doesn't work a %, but that's that's okay.
That's that's the the stakeholders have deemed that
as acceptable for for this demo.
I'll go ahead and get this loaded up
too.
I'm using
the latest version here. I I think I've
migrated my account to I I I haven't
checked out some of the newer Minecraft stuff
in dungeons. I've heard it's a lot of
fun, but I got some coworkers that are
are quite deep into dungeons,
funny enough. But definitely, you need to check
that out later.
Alright.
We'll do this. The music, didn't pipe through,
so it might be a little bit loud
on my end, but whatever. That's just that
makes it more engaging for me. I'll I'll
save you from blowing out your eardrums.
Cool.
Alright.
So
let's go ahead and actually get this
get this service.
Let me pump this up.
Alright.
And
so
oh, that's right.
Let's go ahead and close that. I don't
I use one time logins in my terminal
and so I don't have AWS credentials over
there. Shoot. But I I have them over
here so I'll go ahead and get them
here.
Alright.
So
this is the
cool. This is what I want. This is
going to be the load balancer that is
in front of our Minecraft server.
It's it's all up and running. We check
the logs. We're good to go. I'm gonna
go ahead and pull those logs back up
so you can actually see me join into
that session.
Clear the buffer and let's do a direct
connection. We can see we've got a load
balancer from before.
Clear that out.
Join that server and then we should see
only dull is my moniker over here. We
could actually see that I've joined the game.
I can run around. Hopefully, this isn't clipping
too bad for for anyone. I think I've
done some streams in the past and spend
like lag lag lag. But
but yeah, we could we could enhance this.
We could add in the ability to like
jump and fly.
This is just very very base bone bare
bones right now. Not not too much functionality
added, you know, pretty pretty static but we've
done it. You know, we could we could
have people all over the world joining our
Minecraft server and we deployed it with Waypoint.
Like David said,
quite a quite a few many opportunities to
we could enhance this. We could add entry
points.
We could even add, like, configuration map integration
with Kubernetes.
We could add in some secrets of vaults
and kinda make something shift around and change.
And it seems you've got me thinking, David.
I might have to let you know when
we have a v two of this demo
because that's I I didn't realize how much
more we could actually do. This would be
kind of fun.
That Awesome. That concludes my my demos. I'll
go ahead and disconnect. You'll see that I
just left the game, and that is that's
Waypoint, folks.
Awesome. Thank you very much for that. Let
me pop us back over
here.
Yeah.
Three really great demos. Nothing went wrong, annoyingly.
Well done.
I think each
of those demos really helped cement the idea
of where Waypoint fits in, what its responsibilities
are, and I think that's the the best
takeaway we can get here. In fact, we
got a a comment to send demos great.
It shows how Waypoint is progressing and I
do get it more than when it's first
released. Yeah. Me too.
I I I was confused. Today, I'm no
longer confused. So thank you very much for
that. We got another comment from Russell w.
I find we do things differently here equals
we never read the documentation.
Yeah. There's there's probably
a bit of that.
That's funny. Alright. Awesome. So if anyone has
any more questions in the chat, you've got
about one or two minutes to get it
in. Otherwise, we will be saying goodbye and
leaving it there.
So what's next for Waypoint? Can you share
any any juicy gossip of us?
Yeah. Yeah. So that's it's and and one
of the fun things too. I used to
work at Walt Disney Studios prior to working
at Hashicorp, and so it was very difficult
to talk about. You can't talk about movies
and things that are happening. So I I
I do like being able to work more
in open source and being able to talk
and and kinda share on that front. But
so so really so, zero five was really
focused on this visibility,
this governance,
this, you know, input variables, OpenID Connect, those
statuses that that I just kinda, like, very
quickly walked through. And so zero six is
really going to be more focused on platform
is is the initial thought. So when it
comes to making those Kubernetes workflows work better,
if you're running on something like ECS or
Nomad, that's kind of going to be the
the more generic drop in that focus is
what it's looking like right now. So as
we start to, like, do sprint planning and
and identify some more things that we want
to do, you you'll see those things get
added to the zero six milestone within GitHub.
That's the best place to tune in and
check to check things out.
I think that there might have been a
public board at one point in time, but
I'd say milestone's probably the best thing to
take a look at
if if you're curious on things that are
upcoming or things that got kinda pulled down
and and planned as it moves into those
phases. So I'm really excited to see what
makes it. As with any release, you know,
there's things that get worked on, things that
don't make the cut that fall on the
the cutting room floor.
But the good news about that is they
don't get put in as DVD extras. They
probably just get deferred to a later release
or a minor release. So that's that's always
good to know.
Awesome.
We have a tongue in cheek question from
Russell. So which movies are HashiCorp Studios releasing
next?
It's I I I can't talk about that.
I I can't talk about that. But
maybe
maybe we could talk with Mitchell and Arman
about that. You know? Maybe we wanna start
up a new a new studio. It seems
like there are a lot of streaming platforms
now.
Definitely learned some things at at previous job
with the with streaming platforms. So I'll get
back to you on that. Yeah. I mean,
Mitchell might be looking for some new things
to do. Now he's got a bit more
time. So maybe maybe HashiCorp Studios is the
next venture. Right?
Alright. I don't think we're gonna get any
more questions. So, Taylor, I'm gonna leave it
there. I'm gonna say thank you so much
for joining us.
Really, really great demos. They they really helped
my understanding of Waypoint and others. So thank
you for that. And hopefully, we get to
do something again soon. So have a wonderful
day, and I'll speak to you later.
Thank you so much, David. Thanks everybody for
joining. Cheers. Bye.